culture and it's laborious emergence
from the immediacy of substantial life
must always begin by getting acquainted
with general principles and points of
view so as at first to work up to a
general conception of the real issue as
well as learning to support and refute
the general conception with reasons then
to apprehend the rich and concrete
abundance of life by differential
classification and finally to give
accurate instruction and past serious
judgment upon it from its very beginning
culture must leave room for earnestness
for the earnestness of life in its
concrete richness this leads the way to
an experience of the real issue and when
the even when the real issue has been
penetrated to its depths by serious
speculative effort this kind of knowing
and judging will still retain its
appropriate place in ordinary
conversation
okay now this is a very short and very
important dense little paragraph there's
quite a lot going on here
not only because Hegel is bringing in a
bunch of new conceptions that are
fleshing out his idea of what it is that
he's aiming at what it is that he
attempts to produce in this work but
because these are going to play a major
role in the very structure of the work
so he starts out talking about culture
and I think that when we see this word
culture we don't want to assume
automatically culture as a finished
thing we want to think about the process
of becoming cultured because quite often
that's what he's going to be focusing on
so he's talking about culture and his
laborious emergence emergence from one
from what what he calls substantial life
now this requires some some lingering
over this and some explanation Hegel
thinks that in many societies and in
many people's experience they're at the
point that he's looking at them caught
up in what he calls substantial life
where think about this term substance
substances are what are real what
actually are out there the things you
can bump into there they're the things
that matter they have value oftentimes
they're they're sort of a self evidenc
about them so your substantial life as a
student could include things like
needing to buy your books you just sort
of take that for granted as part of
student life but then somebody could
come along and say why buy books why not
simply read them why not get an
electronic version of the text that
perhaps you can download through a
torrent not not advising this by the way
just pointing it out as a way in which
the unity and the sort of sleep
sleepiness a substantial life can be
shaken and then broken and somebody says
oh yeah yeah now they're actually posed
with what should I do it should before I
was just going to go this way and I
wasn't even going to think about it now
I have to decide do I go this way or
this way or this way which one's better
how do I figure out which one is better
mmm I have to I have to you know discuss
this and you could like fall back into
substantial life he calls this immediacy
meaning that there's nothing mediating
it it is just mediating itself it's sort
of what in other philosophical
traditions you know the later
phenomenology of whose rule they would
call the natural attitude or you know
when he when him or when doing kind of
was talking about his dogmatic slumbers
that could be something like substantial
life so what is culture culture is
coming out of substantial life not
necessarily throwing it away altogether
or demonizing it saying oh it's terrible
it's horrible we have to always be
thinking constantly and examining
everything don't ever take anything for
granted that can by the way become its
own substantial life the hippie-dippie
you know question everything that turns
into its own kind of weird constricted
substantial life that Hegel calls
skepticism later in any case culture is
an emergence from substantial life
through acquiring general principles
general principles are something more
than just following along with the rules
kind of not blindly but but unthinkingly
general principles are things that you
can actually identify as hey these are
principles now that you may have good
principles or bad principles he's not
concerned about it at that point but
having general principles allows you to
arrive at
a articulate thought or conception a way
of seeing things again Danka in this of
what of the real issue of what it is
that you want to study so again if we
want to use power relations in real life
worlds or or what other people call
cultures not what Hegel's calling
culture culture ation you have all sorts
of power relations
some people are higher some people are
lower there's expectations that go along
with it habits help form this you know
reward and Punishment effect this and
people come to sort of take this is just
this is just the way things are and then
they start thinking about general
principle why are why are things this
way
well because it's better for all of
society or the ancestors decided this so
then you start thinking in terms of
general principles and there's a
critical element to this so if the
ancestors went along with this does this
mean that everything that the ancestors
did is automatically good how do we
apply that principle and you start to
arrive at more and more sophisticated
more and more self articulating forms of
thought and those are what allow you to
pull yourself out of substantial life so
and that's what allows you to understand
the thing the Zaka if you want to
understand power relations you have to
exercise your mind and exude a sort of
dissolving substance to a certain degree
thereby there was a famous philosopher
and i can't remember who it was it was a
materialist who said the mind secretes
thoughts the way that the stomach
secretes liver secretes bile and i think
able to sort of go along with that the
active mind actually secretes thoughts
which cling to things which you know
latch into them thoughts are an active
an active process so to think about
power relations is already in a certain
respect to begin to question them I mean
you might come back to the primary say
hey I'm all for them whoever's on top
good for you
everyone else should obey but that's
different than the sort of unthinking
dreamy sleepy substantial wife so what
is the person end up learning how to do
who is cultured I only put one thing up
your classification but Hegel talks
about being able to support or being
able to to contradict or criticize the
general conception that one has by
giving reasons by considering you know
arguments we could say to apprehend the
rich and concrete abundance of life by
differential classification differential
classification means saying how things
are actually different from each other
so going back to power relations once
again as an example merely an example
the person now by having some sort of
way of looking at things some sort of
theoretical way of looking at things is
able to be in classifying things in the
realm of concrete experience and doing
that that act of classification helps
make these things more understandable
more intelligible it removes them from
their immediacy because now they're
mediated through the classification to
be able to get accurate instruction and
past serious judgment upon it part of
culture is passing on culture every
generation of students that come into
our classrooms for us educators are in
the place where we were a general in my
case a generation ago for some
professors two generations ago for some
professors newly-minted just you know
where they were a few years before and
what we have to do
to them what we have to awaken in them
what we have to inculcate in them is
what was done with us and it's going to
be somewhat different from case to case
to case of course now I was going to be
just you know stamping out a process of
a mere imitation or you know mere
replication we're helping them to become
culture to become culture for Hegel
means to be able to think about things
to pull yourself out of the society the
way of thinking that everybody else
around you has and think in general
terms be able to hold on to those
thoughts be able to provide reasons to
be able to think about that to think
about thinking to be able to classify
and to be able to teach others to be
able to pass that on and to be able to
pronounce judgments that are not just
some made up pulled out of the air
feeling or opinion but actually have
some sort of basis so this is what
culture consists of we might think about
it as culture and education and
development all rolled into one so he
says from it's very beginning culture
must leave room for the earnestness of
life in its concrete richness our lived
lives are extremely rich if we actually
pay attention to what's going on in them
you know people talk these days about
mindfulness people like Hegel were doing
mindfulness and doing it on you know
infinitely higher power than these these
mindfulness practitioners that that go
around and get paid for doing these
workshops today even suspect because
he's saying our immediate lives if we
pay attention them are extremely rich
the problem is we need to be able to
make sense out of what is actually going
on in them so we have a sort of fork a
fork in the road at this point he says
even when the real issue has been
penetrated to its depths by serious
speculative
effort that's sort of what he's
sketching out here it's always possible
for us to fall back into this I think a
lot of educators themselves fall back
into a kind of substantial life of how
they conceive education and how
everybody else talks about it you know I
see this happening in a lot of different
venues education theory and you know
what people call assessment which you
know sometimes isn't really assessment
course design all these sorts of things
it's easy to fall into a kind of analog
tutu group thing and I don't want to use
the word groupthink because it has these
sinister connotations because of 1984
just think of it as sort of a nice warm
room in which the nutrients are
constantly flowing and there's not a lot
of struggle required real thoughts for
Hegel requires struggle
the true shape in which truth exists can
only be the scientific system of such
truth to help bring philosophy closer to
the form of science to the goal where it
can lay aside the title love of knowing
and be actual knowing that is what I
have set myself to do the intern assess
'ti that knowing should be science lies
in its nature and only the systematic
exposition of philosophy itself provides
it but the external necessity so far as
it is grasped in a general way
setting aside accidental matters of
person and motivation is the same as the
inner or in other words it lies in the
shape in which time sets forth the
sequential existence of its moments to
show that now is the time for philosophy
to be raised to the status of a science
would therefore be the only true
justification of any effort that has the
same for to do so would demonstrate the
necessity of the aim would indeed at the
same time be the accomplishing of it
and this section Hegel is really
charting out for you in a very positive
straightforward way some of the main
themes and thrusts of this this work and
he's got this great catchphrase which
may bother some people depending on
their theory of truth he talks about the
true shape of truth often times when you
see this word shape or structure you
want to think in terms of Gestalt
and that's an important term for for
Hegel on the true form the true mode the
manifestation of the true articulate
Ness of it it's possible for truth in
Hegel system or a truth at a certain
point to be less than fully true that
may be able to mind-blowing for some how
can true actually be sort of a predicate
of itself but we'll get to that some of
these things you have to sort of take on
faith until we get a little bit further
further on it in the phenomenology that
was part of the point that he was making
about how hard it is to write a preface
but their truth is going to be a
criteria for itself and this is not a
completely new idea you know the
medievals have this conception of the
the truth is actually the criterion for
itself and for falsity now truth is
something for Hegel that develops that
is active that involves the sort of
subjectivity and a sort of agency so
truth is going to be able to reflect
upon itself at certain points and say
well I'm not completely true I need to
be truer than I what I am really
interesting thought that's going to be a
lot of fun for us to polite
now Hegel will say that the only way in
which truth in a you know philosophical
sense
and that means again the best sense for
hanging all right the best most
expansive most encompassing sense the
only way in which that is going to be
able to be fully presented fully
consolidated is in terms of a scientific
system of truth so that means taking in
truths in the the multiple and making
them all part of one big truth without
distorting them in the process without
you know leaving parts out that don't
fit you have to find some way to
actually synthesize all of this together
huge challenge and you have to do so in
a systematic way that means that things
can't all just be left out like on a
work batch you know cluttered up they
can't all be placed into their their
compartments and have no connection with
each other there are integral
connections with each other have to be
part of the very system itself the
system itself has to be scientific
meaning that it has to be oriented
towards knowledge that is actually
assured of itself as knowledge that's
not how we often think of science when
we do think of that we usually think of
the scientific method and hypothesis and
then it starts to get very hazy for most
of us because we've forgotten what we
learned in our high school science
classes or the college classes that we
had to take but you know the
experimental method is really only part
of what makes science science it's also
being able to provide explanations that
can be you know correlated to other
things and actually philosophers of
science and scientists themselves will
often get into debates and disputes
about precisely what counts as science
precisely what scientific method entails
so it's not quite as cut and dry as
people would like to thank for Hegel to
be scientific means that it is going to
necessarily be systematic and it's
oriented towards generating a type of
knowledge so he says for philosophy the
question is is it going to remain
love of knowing that drives it or is it
going to proceed to actual knowing is
philosophy going to quit puttering
around or quit developing quit being
something potential and become something
actual become actual knowledge
articulated in a systematic way
scientifically to provide an
understanding of the totality without
leaving anything out putting each thing
in its in its appropriate place
including the one who is putting things
in place tall order so he says the inner
necessity that knowing should be science
lies in its nature knowledge by its very
nature wants to be science it desires to
become science it wants you to think
about you know a bit of knowledge
doesn't just want to sit in your head by
itself it wants to be correlated to
other things it wants to be brought into
a system with other parts as sort of
moments of a constellation moments of a
greater whole and you can go along with
that or you can resist it and some of
our habits you know tend to tend to
resist that so he says the the external
necessity so far as it's grasped in a
general way setting aside accidental
matters of person and motivation here's
how we we want to be scientific is the
same as the inner or in other words it
lies in the shape in which time sets
forth the sequential existence of its
moments remember we talked about
development before that's part of what
it means to have this scientific
systematic way of looking at things
doesn't mean by the way that you would
have to totally exclude your own
personality your own concrete experience
from things but we do want to generalize
we do want to learn how to as I just
said in the previous section go through
that process of becoming cultured that
is part of the process of attaining
truth
/ Hegel so what else do we have in here
there's a clarion call that's taking
place here and this is really important
he says just show that now is the time
for philosophy to be raised to the
status of the science what that would
mean is philosophy is actual going
actually becomes science
it hasn't been so before that's why the
scientists and that's why the you know
somewhat skeptical philosophers like you
know contant some of his writings and
definitely Hume can say the history of
philosophy up until this point has been
a history of errors is there's nothing
scientific about it you know why because
it's never actually been fully brought
to its realization in actual knowing
through some sort of scientific system
of truth these go together with each
other
Hegel saying the time is now and who's
the guy to pull it off Hegel not because
Hegel is you know himself smarter than
Plato or Aristotle he is pretty pretty
brilliant I mean you have to give him
math but he doesn't think of himself is
more brilliant than those guys he
happens to occupy the right time and
place
this process of development has been has
been occurring through the centuries
through the millennia and not just in
philosophy but through all the different
things that fall under culture like law
like politics like economics like
religion like art all of these have been
leading up to a crux in a person who's
now going to be in the right place at
the right time to finally bring
philosophy to the level of development
that it is been desiring to be at
without fully understanding what that
would mean this entire time this is why
he says to show that now is the time for
philosophy to be raised to the status of
a science would be the only true
justification of any effort that has
this aim the proof of whether Hegel is
successful
lies in the entirety of the
phenomenology of spirit this entire
system in order to pass judgment upon
Hegel what that means is if he's right
about this you would have to be able to
go through and understand all of the
moments and all the dialectics all of
the the state the shapes of
consciousness and the entire process of
development and then you'd be able to
say yeah I think he got right or you got
it wrong in these respects by the way I
actually do think that he got it wrong
in certain respects and that the
dialectic is not as simple as he he made
it out to be and I'm not you know I'm
not the only person who thinks so you
know really if you're going to
philosophize after Hegel and want to be
in some respect a dialectical
philosopher you probably have to
disagree with him on that respect around
that topic but before you do that you
need to actually see how all these
things fit together Hegel saying the
only way that you can adequately judge
the system as a whole is on the basis of
looking at the system as a whole not
just a part of it definitely not just
the you know thesis antithesis synthesis
triangle and saying well that doesn't
apply to everything Hegel would say
that's not exactly what we mean by
scientific system
to lay down that the true shape of truth
is scientific or what is the same thing
to maintain the truth is only the notion
as the element of its existence seems I
know to contradict of you which is in
our time is prevalent as it is
pretentious and to go against what that
view implies some explanation therefore
seems to be called for even though it
must for the present be no more than a
bare assertion like the view that it
contradicts if namely the true exists
only in what or better as what is
sometimes called intuition sometimes
immediate knowledge of the absolute
religion or being not at the center of
divine love but the being of divine love
itself then what is required in the
exposition of philosophy is from this
viewpoint rather the opposite of the
form of the notion for the absolute is
not supposed to be comprehended it is
supposed to be felt and intuitive not
the notion of the absolute but the
feeling and intuition of it must govern
what is said and be expressed by it
now in this section Hale is going to
begin to engage in some more criticism
some of the prevalent points of view in
in the world of thought of his own time
and he's starting out by saying if it's
really the case that the shape of truth
is necessarily scientific or put in
another way or what's equivalent to say
that truth has only the notion we'll
come back to that in a moment now is the
element of its existence then what did
what do the implications does that have
that means that oversimplifying ways of
trying to apprehend truth are not going
to be successful they may appear to be
successful and that's exactly what's
wrong with them that they can actually
seduce you off the path the laborious
systematic process oriented path the
truth and think that you can sort of
just shoot yourself at like a cannon
ball directly at the real at the matter
itself at the truth and then you can
actually arrive there so what is he
going to contrast to this in this
paragraph he brings up this term put a
dividing line here intuition there there
are some and they included philosophers
you would say that in order to grasp
truth you can't do it many sort of
mediated way any sort of conceptual
systematic scientific way it has to be
through intuition it has to be when we
say intuition what we mean is some sort
of direct unmediated
grasp of truth or reality so some people
you know talk about mystical experience
in terms like this you know mystical
experience is a very deep and vexed
topic so I don't want to over generalize
but some people use the word mystical
basically to mean things that are
matters of intuition you can also say
that some things are matters of
intuition necessarily like you know
sensation to a certain extent fits into
that how do you know if you're in pain
well you actually feel that you're in
pain of course it's not quite so simple
once we start looking at it carefully
and we start realizing that pain is a
relationship between nerves and the
brain and how we feel about things and
external things now suddenly it's
actually mediated but some people have
this notion that you could have an
unmediated direct apprehension of truth
not only that you could but that's the
way it has to be so for example Spinoza
who hang a life quite a bit for some
some you know parts of his philosophy
Spinoza thinks that ultimately we need a
type of knowledge that's of substance or
God that is not like the discursive kind
of knowledge that we have Hegel would
say no discursive knowledge is where
it's at and this is where this this word
notion comes in it also gets translated
in other versions as concept and this is
a really important bit of Hegel's
philosophy the graph in german is what's
being translated here and the guy Fionn
means to literally to sort of like grip
onto right and if you think about it
when you're when you're wrapping your
mind around something you're not just
like having one sort of lightning bolt
of intuition you're doing a process
where you're kind of think about feeling
somebody's face and their features and
figuring out who they are
maybe doing you know maybe it's
enjoyable or maybe you're horrified by
what you find on their face it's gap
there's parts to the process and those
parts are all connected to each other in
one one main structure or or Gestalt one
main hole and the parts of that hole are
things that you can just take away and
have the same the same thing the same
experience same understanding the same
comprehension philosophy as the study of
the real as the study of the totality as
the study of what's what's most true
even the nature of truth Hegel thinks
can't afford to lapse into flights of
intuition but has to try to work out
things in terms of the notion in terms
of a scientific systematic understanding
of things so it says if the true exists
only in what or better as what is
sometimes called intuition sometimes
immediate knowledge of the absolute
religion or being not at the center of
divine mode but the being of divine love
itself I mean this is part of what makes
it so attractive to talk about intuition
because it's like I want to have a
direct experience I don't want my
experience mediated with words and
concepts and knowledge I want to have
the thing itself right on top of me or
in me or I want to be in it I want to
experience reality directly some people
try to do this by the way through their
their senses they figure if I just get
out there and serve or if I you know get
myself into a fight or try to you know
are having sex you know for a moment all
like experience unmediated reality
itself but that's the problem one moment
and from a galilean perspective that one
moment thing isn't even that one moment
all you remember is your reconstruction
of that later on and that's not quite
the same thing as something that
sustains over
I'm that you can you can actually carry
around with you as an integral part of
who you are so he says the absolute is
not supposed to be comprehended for
these people it's must be felt into it
not the notion of the absolute but the
feeling and intuition of it must govern
what it said and must be expressed by it
Hegel thinks that this is a
fundamentally misguided way of going
about things and no it's worth thinking
for a moment before we go on to the next
section why would people as
sophisticated as for example Spinoza say
we need to have this this intuitive
knowledge this third type of knowledge
in the Spinoza's case of what is most
real it's really from Hegel's
perspective a failure of nerve it's not
an optimism it's really a kind of
pessimism about our own human capacity
to make our way to the absolute by way
of progressively integrated Li
synthesizing knowledge bit by bit by bit
painful bit laborious bit which is an
achievement for us
intuition is kind of cheap like the easy
man's way and the problem that he's
going to talk about a little bit later
on you don't know whether your intuition
is actually an intuition of something or
whether you're just kind of making it up
and whether your neurons are kind of
spinning out so he's engaging in some
criticism here in this section and he's
going to continue this criticism for a
bit as well in other sections